I haven't done this in a while but I'm
gonna just click this button and see
what happens hopefully I'll get the game
I only have time for a few games so try
and make this somewhat decent quality if
it takes too long I might join this
Eastern bullet arena we'll see it's
10:58 p.m. on a Tuesday the arena starts
in two minutes so will I get a game in
less than two minutes I guess we'll find
out tournament
okay handful of players about 2,000
weight starts in 45 seconds okay I'm not
playing the 10-minute game it took too
long I'm gonna join the tournament
it starts in 40 seconds I'm the top seed
my bullet rating took a huge dip maybe I
can go to my profile and you'll see the
rating graph let's go like six months
where's my bullet rating so here's my
bullets I peaked at 2665 a few weeks ago
and now I just plummeted what happened I
guess this is around the time I decided
to move in to the chest bra cave it did
not have a great effect on my rating
all right so well now I'm getting
challenges but I just joined the
tournament I'm so conflicted now hello
to people in the chat geom John Davis
one of the first viewers and Joe Grune
or one of the first chatters and what
does this name Malu
cookbook now I feel like cooking let's
cook up some opening preparation this is
a nice move order I play the reverse
camp Cambridge Springs I think I can
still do it it's more
holding the bishops here Queen d7
usually gets hit with 95 and now bucks
in trouble Queen can move here here to
defend the night but then it's aligned
with the bishop it's now I'm winning a
queen and a pawn and maybe another pawn
attacking the rook and then I'll win
this pawn life is so good I have two
outside pass pawns and I'm up a queen
and I'm trapping this rook can life get
any better I guess I could castle then
my king will be safe let's play b3 whoa
this Knight is asking to be trapped play
rook FC 1 and then f3
Oh the Knights actually trapped now that
was kind of unexpected no it's on g5 or
not usually the best Knights all right
now I'll push a pond or I'll push a
future Queen oh let's save the rook
now this Knight is asking to be trapped
let's just take a pawn ooh
ok I don't want to lose my future Queen
there we go there we go
mmm let's attack this pawn attacking the
rook aligning with a king mmm let's take
a free rook let's take a free night
check ok the future Queen is now a
present Queen Queen FA does mates okay
that was how's interesting Samsonite's
as going to bed it's so early the day is
just beginning or the night is just
beginning
or the Queen is just beginning all right
um I mean do people want to see me play
bullets or do people want to see me play
against viewers like instructive and
maybe more normal chess let me just get
some feedback from the chat and then
I'll make up my mind
whether to stay with this tournament or
play against people standard 69 bits for
instructive normal instructive games
please says the singing Mountain against
viewers instructed normal instructive no
one wants to see me play bullets you
only want to watch me play bullet if I
win every game
hahaha what if okay here's a plan
instructed bullets I'm gonna play bullet
until I lose and then I'll play
challenges so I'm not allowed to lose or
draw I have to win every game I'll make
it challenging for myself
I'll beserk every game and I'll be more
likely to lose and then viewers will be
more likely to be happy oops I just
dropped a bishop it's a problem with
talking and playing so now I'm buzzer
King so ty mods and Bishop odds
basically look like night here attack
the pawn h6 is coming yeah good double
up rooks maybe each 395 looks nice a
three will be nice attack the bishop
won't play Knight c5 I want the Queen's
will lead the battery I'd c5 stole maybe
presence and I hear he's gonna win the
e5 pawn I'll have open ian d files i
want to put the Queen here and meet on
each seven what's the likelihood on me
on h7 longer I think the more it gives
it away that's why that move he
obviously sees it he's gonna play
something like that I'm gonna play ooh
wait I'm winning now maybe I'm with a
queen still down on time but I'm up a
queen stopple up rooks c4 I'll post with
a knight back
so nights are very annoying three nights
take on g6 if I get a chance okay I'll
take their meat please
yes mates with zero point nine five
seconds left it's a miracle
do not deserve to win that but maybe I
did third place
berserk you guys are gonna have to wait
a bit longer
go silver all the zerk again mmm what is
this position I want to take twice
mm-hmm okay let's play e5 mmm five looks
nice maybe nice for whites play this in
f6
Queen e7 just defend King h8 not a great
position hey Ben counter strike with
subbing are his gifting subs Caruana
blitz Catherine I would read them all
but I would maybe lose on time play g6
try and we can like structure a little
bit this is a very close position that
was a good move each six but their work
on each eights that goes back we're
gonna trade everything White's gonna win
each seven I try and get my queen to h8
and then each one whoa free bishop don't
think like counted correctly I'll win
the d3 pawn maybe the Knights pinned now
in thread oh I had 90 takes e4 let's
defend my queen maybe I'll but now I'm
up on time
defense e6 defense e6 again night p7
trenching trying to trap the Queen okay
now I'm just trying to fog him another
buzzer Quinn thanks for the sub gifts
bean oh it's bean counter strike 25
Carwin applets guy incog Manjaro black
Kothari and the bob broken soul welcome
to the sub club stop buzzer King but
that's I mean that's how I'm gonna like
eventually loses by buzzer King so I
know people want to play and have more
instructive chests so I'm gonna keep his
irking unless you bribe me let's take
here let's take your fun line this is
actually a really funny line Queen e7
confuses a lot of people taking on e4
next it's my queen see if I prevent
light from castling Bishop e3 is coming
along when the b2 pong maybe or maybe
not
yeah now it's just kind of a normal
position on Castle I have double pawns
White has an IQ e our weights isolate an
i KP I so the King's pawn got confused
for a moment there let's play rock TX
maybe rook T 2 can be prima ghost or
maybe not let's play rook d7 okay
doubling up g6 in Queen g7 alfie and
kettle the Queen because it makes me
feel safe and I win the pawn queen h3
maybe next Queen takes g4 next good
trade Queens I'll be happy
New York d2 my getting made in h6 age 6
I can take on h2 thankfully and then
maybe I'm meeting first rook d1 looks
like almost makes
okay this is good enough trade
everything into an end game I'll convert
the King pawn ending I have enough Hans
okay
good game all right I'm buzzer King and
winning continuously who's gonna stop me
if people want me to lose I'll lose when
the time comes but for the time being
I'm winning the thought of playing us is
driving Erik to play his best chess ever
says Jon Davis it might be correct I
just really don't want to play you guys
all I have lost a bishop maybe I do want
to play you guys supreme move stuff he 5
was dirty I'm down material on time c3
good try Bishop d3 let's go for the
checkmating trick again already made
into it's play King g2 you'll take with
Queen d5 is attacked let's try and win
the D pawn threatening Queen c4 well you
see it didn't see it but he wins would
be to pawn I'll win that five maybe okay
it's tricky I play Bishop to be one
blockade and then Queen C to go for the
tricky maid again please take my rope
please see what else does black - I
guess g6 actually play this move go for
h5
check ah this is a check I'm my winning
this somehow someway maybe this move
defending be one okay there should be
four I have two queens
two queens should be enough things black
had a chance to promote their okay I'm
so fast well I didn't know I was that
fast
okay I'd worked every game it's except
the first game hey we have a new sub
afar saying thanks for subbing never
mind I don't want to play you anymore am
I too scary I'll donate $100 if you
beaten Nakamura and bullet while be
seeking while buzzer King I've never
been Nakamura in bullet while like being
normal or just trying my when time I
beat Nakamura it's like 15 minutes back
in the ICC days mmm that's a good move
this is gonna be painful again let's
take that and go over the pots our
attack h4 h5 g4 and hope for the best
can take a - what's going on here whoa
this is made into if you took with F
pawn I'd be losing now I'm winning back
to tournament 25 points all right I'm
gonna play this guy next McKellen's
winning all his games mmm
I'm doing my best penguin impression
wait penguin as in like the animal or
the tang okay I'm playing this guy let's
play let's play another London
well like d5 was kind of random okay
just being solid I want to play e5 let's
play this move Naboo maybe I'll have
Bishop h7 but maybe not defend mate
f4 coming maybe Queen f3 or rook f3 or
b4 I missed a free night let's play b4
here in 94 maybe a 3 first restrict the
Queen a night and now 94 I don't want to
trade your rooks I want to mate though
let's play this move h4 I don't know
what I'm doing though play Queen e3 and
now pin the night but it's not really
pinned mmm well I'm gonna lose h4 no but
he didn't take it I'm losing b4 I have
this move in the end it's not that great
play g4 maybe that's scary I have tricky
ideas like this move I'm mating next
move
yes I was so close to losing that game
thank God for double-check hey more sub
gifts from your Danny wizard wizard wait
you're you're a wizard Danny I don't
know I struggle with that name
thanks for gifting subs a total of 42
the meaning of life - mummy Jamila old
dirty mermaid battle Archangel Witek Oh
or witty with a Keo with T Co and
Phlegethon 5 7 7 8 thanks guys for
gifting subs I'm going to continue so
berserk and hopefully continue to win so
other people playing this tournaments
but I have a lot of fives let's mazurka
again Israel ovitch good luck oh let's
play well i buzzer - okay good
almost forgot abou zerks there I'm a
pawn storm in win Connect four and then
trying minute chess keep on storming
Bishop e7 take take again
rook a7 getting off the diagonal maybe
take the sky - and then light here
whoa that's a scary move let's play f5
defend from a distance I work here so
the D files will only open file I'm
doubled up just not a bad thing on table
low up with my rooks bring the knight
maybe to d3 now the G file is open let's
not lose a queen
I would like to trade Queens mmm bring
the rook back okay my Knights very much
how to play but time is almost equal
he's actually playing a good game
despite their rating might c5 try and
bring the knight in a win he five maybe
I'm envisioning this this and mating on
g1 I mean am I gonna have the double
check again oh that's scary and let's
check me him
oh I'm attacking the bishop hey I'm a
thing on g1 nice point zero two seconds
left I was able to meet before he
flagged okay
so many fives the sky's in second place
with 20 points oh this guy is good I
played another day and my my viewer
tournament this was just yesterday this
was irk again let's play d4 again and
London again b5 ready for e5 now I'll go
for the posture attack again
literally Bishop h6 blacks playing
somewhat slowly now trying to attack f7
play that move prevent black from
castling King side it's still Castle
queenside all attack
maybe Queen can swing over and swing
back so much swinging I'll sack on b5
because why not threatening a6 now still
threatening a6 how Queen a5 will come
I'll win the bishop bring the Queen back
Castle King safety second ofr is a
blunder now I can play e5
Oh d6 is very weak let's invade c4 maybe
coming or mm let's play c4 first and
queen e7 the lights almost trapped has
to move to have for e2 will come
oops or not okay I have enough time
safety first
defend the bishop but forget about my
Knights play this movement takes c6 and
then take the Queen free Queen hey it's
bits it's 10,000 bits from your add any
wizard or you're a wizard Dani I should
be able to pronounce that catch me if
you can
am i how do I catch you you're a Dani
wizard just earned that 25 thousand bits
badge and 69 bits from superly Wow okay
but how do I catch you you have to throw
me to throw me yourself I guess not
great at catching things I'm playing
reactions again I already play them once
oh let's play a staffer gambit or not
oh the signing in okay yeah it kind of
confused him last time okay we're gonna
go into the sign this is about equal I
think we can trade Queens or not please
Castle now I'm preventing kingside
castling well switch gear is will swing
over again the Queen likes to swing
Bishop 83 or maybe Queen takes a to just
immediately queenside castling ooh rook
any one will hurt me thankfully I had
this move so rook takes a seven is not
playable that's playable but should have
to expected that was unexpected let's
play this I'm threatening a variety of a
lot of like appetizing techniques oh I
hung a queen that was not great
thankfully I still have hope this is
pinned in two directions
I'll take with the rook next or maybe
the take with the bishop look at this
counter play attacking the Queen and
threatening double check of multiple
double check so I'll win the Queen back
okay that was kind of a mess thankfully
I'm not losing this also am I'm eating
this is almost me next move the bishop
defends I'll take there okay I was a fun
game thanks again for the bits someone
was asking why they're banned they could
be banned for bit misbehaving on another
channel but I'm not sure maybe they can
be unbanned and then I mean see if they
behave you're a mod I'll leave it up to
you I trust you
also hello - toilet noggin long time no
see
okay let's preserve again let's play a
Stafford gambit again ooh what is this
let's take a pawn
so you can another pawn got him to move
quickly cuz he's playing quickly I'll
defend stuff and develop stuff okay H
files open take the sky and Bishop here
check will be game over King h1 work
takes h2 and Queen h4 mates man to
strong 15 moves I was one of the higher
rated opponents - okay 50 points
not even halfway through the tournament
I'm gonna play the sky like inevitably
and I don't know if I should be zerk but
okay as long as I don't play him on
berserk okay no their London let's play
this line hey more bits from someone box
sounds like a sheep I'm trading
everything ringing get some endgame I'll
I'll post my knight on c5 maybe or maybe
not
that's gonna be annoying like b3 mmm as
is very annoying position I won't get my
knight to e3 let's take a pawn Oh draw
okay let's attack that maybe I'm
surviving here look see - next expecting
rook hf4 let's do this happy with a
trade
play this move okay now we trade life is
slightly better keep rooks on the board
mmm that's a good move or is it useless
and this are hanging maybe I'm winning
the night or the exchange this sack the
exchange back because Knights are scary
push past pawns maybe pre moving time oh
okay that was close
GM John Davis sobbing with a Tier three
three months thanks John Davis it's
already been three months nice
fifty-five wait what does that song it's
like an old song from years ago like two
thousand two thousand fifty sure or is
it schmidtty schmidtty five pause oh I
can't pause okay we're gonna have one
song playing during this game oh no it's
an ad okay
I'm the berserk again this is risky to
do against a high player but he's busy
working - that's good okay this is scary
I read a player with confidence go for
the posture attack again Bishop e2 let's
play for sure 55
okay hmm
this is so distracting the song I'm so
sorry
oh man my king my king my beautiful king
oh no oh no yes okay we're done with
that song I'm so sorry about that
if you guys want to listen to the full
song this is like what is this song 2006
like mid-2000s
okay back to tournaments I'm at 60
points another sub from over nigma still
a difficult name I don't know how many
in a row it is too many fives okay let's
play e5 no one wants to play the
Stafford gambit let's play copycat chess
mm-hmm so whites being greedy but might
be rewarded for it play each six
yeah I'm just down upon a very little
compensation but that's okay I'm gonna
try oh that's an interesting move can
win this and then this G 3 is now week D
3 can't be defended actually down ephors
week Wow
I went from being down upon to being up
to pawns play this move oh that was kind
of a blunder
okay I have to give up the bishop now
I'll have three pawns for the piece oh
no he didn't take what I was so devious
more subs from John Davis but I'm down
the full rook for two pawns ah let's try
and stay focused
everything's defended actually can
please start pre moving again more subs
ten Tier one subs thanks John Davis oh
my gosh I don't know repeat never
repeats who f7 hung free rook ooh
okay I plug them again and you're a
wizard Danny I finally said the name
kind of correct gifting 10 subs as well
and John Davis gifting 10 subs what is
going on and someone's hearing bits but
I don't know what happened to the cheer
cause so many people gifted subs Omar
nygma gifting 500 bits back to
tournament 65 points we're only halfway
through this what's going on I'm playing
this guy vovan Sidora [ __ ] let's play
more chess or whatever justice is d5 I
don't usually play this line so let's be
a playable line though I think maybe
King h8 let's take their and King h8 and
f6 or maybe Bishop it should be six
first mmm-hmm let's play this move yeah
all your new I guess we need a you're a
Danny wizard sub emotes but all the new
subs had access to the john davis emotes
which is being used to lots all right
let's focus put the bishop on d5 i'm
down the pong but there's an last game
though being down a rook no sneaky
checkmate attack against g2 let's not
hang anything
play this move let's play that move King
g8 to find f7 make Luther for the King I
want to put the Queen on d5 this is
annoying maybe be too threatening G to
defend from afar expecting f6 that was a
good move oh no I'm getting made it no I
didn't want to sink that far
well this chair is actually really
comfortable I was really sad do I start
playing people now or do I finish the
tournament my streak is over
pause the tournaments 65 points terrible
I think I just end the tournament there
are AP pieces all those neighbors well
they're not upset I'm making too much
noise
keep going moral support continue don't
stop what what is it finish tourney
finish trim and keep going on outside so
weather oh you're outside I'm so sorry
oh my gosh I'm so sorry haha I'll buzz
you in
wait just call me I'll buzz you in now
I'm having people over believe it or not
like I know people in real life and
they're like trying to enter my
apartment oh man
okay I'll play one more game but I'll
have to buzz you in as I'm playing the
game so call me whenever wait john davis
is outside too I mean all you have to do
is call me I'm oh hello hello
did that work
oh my gosh well opening up wait hello
I don't know if that worked
tell me in the chat if that works oh my
gosh this is such a bad position but now
it's a better position Bishop e3 will
come Bishop c5 will come Queen c1 will
come more bits will come clean e7 mate
maybe will come I don't win h7 okay the
goal is to do this this and meet on e7
he's confusing me though let's take that
first and then this and then that and
rook d6 and Queen h4 back oh it's very
close to working ooh it's working okay
I'm up a piece still gonna take some
work
rook b8 please yes oh okay now I can pre
move stuff black can't do anything with
the bishop Wow
such a closed position take all the
pawns good game wait are you here wait
let me open the door did that work
I'm gonna wait until after the game I
would call you back but I mean okay just
feel free to call in whenever whoa
10,000 bits from John Davis gaining
rating - I am gaining reading back to
tournaments okay you're calling again
hello hello
are you there wait oh you're here okay
nine I'm playing chess Network
oh he just hung up on me um do i bezerk
I don't buzzer I need time to open the
door when he arrives how am i playing
chess network let's play on London but
he also plays a London oh man it's Jerry
I was watching really old chest Network
videos yesterday like his first video is
like over ten years ago play h3 here my
teach for I'm so nervous
this guy's like a celebrity more bits
what was that sound
let's take a look you just hung a rook
such a nice guy play this move oh it's
more bits I think those might be old
notifications but thanks for the bits Oh
people are here oh I forgot about that
no problem hey how's it going
have you guys heard of chest network I'm
playing him right now this is so
terrifying
Gerry I'm kind of winning but it's kind
of complicated let's play this I want to
make from behind check check King c1
Kirk here I need the other hook to come
from behind
maybe this move okay I'm about to meet
him his King has no legal moves for okay
Jo he's gonna play g5 so sneaky g5 rogue
h7 oh that move is he gonna meet me
first
rook c4 Knight takes e4 no checks that
move I forgot about I beat Jerry nice
okay
back to Trina's look at the score you
guys want to see this 70 points also
this is these are people if you want it
I mean if you want to pop in yeah you
guys want you guys work at the Chess
Club and you guys sometimes are in the
chat
it's working in its more bits from over
enigma I'll be done in like 20 minutes
so oh my gosh time odds
let's do this cuz why not
alright a queen e7 and then Queen h4 and
then 94 or Bishop g4 mmm 94 next 22 6
kingi to please blonde cloud style no
okay attack b2 all right Queen B 4 Queen
a3 King safety Brooke ooh let's trade
Queens always play f5 Rock ooh let's not
remove that okay
I'm gonna try Oh the bishops trapped but
9.3 chops my rook weights I can take
that okay I'm up the exchange for two
pawns but time is almost equal play this
move and take that check okay now it's
just a time scramble I'm gonna try and
win this let's do that move take that
move the rook far away so I can't get
Forks and that move I'm back I have to
give spy checks spy checks for the win
okay back to tournaments I have 75
points I'm gonna try and break a hundred
before this tournament ends I mean this
guy's was like really close behind his
52 points I only had like a almost 20
point lead now I have a 23 point lead
it's not too bad alright the King
checkmater is berserk ooh what is this
position free pawn let's just play very
solidly Spanish Knight maneuver H 4 H 5
H 5 H for taking the f5 e for oh that's
my voice let's take let's play this move
I want to bring the Knight to g6 and not
as a queen all free work or exchange
do that move always clicking b8 let's
play this move and triple up on the file
and pawn chain ok triple up has been
accomplished
queenie one check maybe let's do that
first ok this is meaning this better be
meaning rook g1 coming or queen takes G
- ooh
some nice rucksack mm-hmm
more more bits from double Oh black
double oh I'm yeah I'm getting rained on
there are a lot of like generous
donations there are sub donations bit
donations a lot of like checkmate
donations alright let's play E for Ivan
play d4 at all really I'll have a two
Knights attack we're gonna have a very
similar structure compared to last game
I put the bishop there and that's yeah
this is a fun line a lot of moves can be
pre moved play a for EBP 3b
ok now I want to play f4 eventually our
queen takes g7 eventually g6 ooh not g6
let's play Bishop h6 I really attacked
the pawn okay now it's a skewer I'm
winning a full rook because the rooks
were not connected Knights stuck on d6
play 96 next Knight g4 next maybe Bishop
e5 next actually go for some random
mates go back okay I'm up before rook
doing ok on time let's move back Knight
f3 and 9 H for coming
mm-hmm play this move and then this move
seventh heaven threatening meeting one
up on time H for prophylaxis try ok back
to turn Mints this is going pretty well
and 15 points away from a hundred oh I
lost one game that was tragic but it's
okay to learn from my mistakes
hmm Nicola Lee chess I don't know why
I'm buzzer King them one point away from
2500 slightly this line and this line
all right Queen h5 that move by f4 I
have to go like crazy to win this so the
time disadvantage is so difficult
Oh f3 that's what I need maybe Bishop f5
next defend the pawn first and then this
[ __ ] f5 and then Knight g4 ok h4 is
gonna come and then maybe rookie 6 oh
this is so close to winning let's take a
free pawn this is so close to winning
okay my pawns defended Queen takes h4
doesn't work let's defend again my time
now
can't slay that move take and take your
good move this is difficult this is
really difficult if I lose this game the
stream will end hey how's it going oh no
no I there's so many people what's up
guys how many people are watching do you
want to say hi to over 200 people or no
you want to know side people no okay
alright I will play one more room
there's people here sorry for the chests
more people competing for my attention I
have to finish with a win and then I'm
gonna end things and hopefully a
peaceful way I don't think this guy okay
we'll play this guy I play him already
maybe play g4 g5 okay final game moment
of truth
play this move and this move and Queen
h5 am I gonna win I might be winning
this is completely crushing Wow i won
he dropped all his pieces I think this
is a good place to end it because
there's like there's physical people
here I don't know if you guys know what
physical people are but they're people
that exist in real life apart from the
twitch chats so I mean the end things I
want to thank everyone again like thank
you so much John Davis you're a wizard
Danny cheering sixteen thousand six
hundred bits this month John Davis with
a 10,000 bits donation new subs okay
I'll do a viewer challenge stream I know
I owe you guys
because I was going to do one earlier it
but then I got distracted with his
tournaments I'll probably put this on
YouTube
so for the YouTube people watching in
the future I'll leave a link to my
stream schedule in the video description
so you guys know when the next of your
tournament will be and I'll see you guys
in the future